i'd say the biggest challenge in terms
of filmmaking was
the underwater tunnels months of
training hours underwater and facing
intense fears were all part of a regular
day at work for the cast filming
underwater scenes for the harry potter
films i'm a terrible swimmer i'm really
really bad while he was filming the
underwater portion of the tri-wizard
tournament daniel radcliffe wound up
suffering two ear infections due to all
the time spent under the chilly water in
tests the team had tried to strap
radcliffe upside down in the water so
his hair would float up but it wound up
not being an ideal way to work so they
scrapped it since the giant filming tank
wasn't even heated it's no surprise the
actors weren't fans and radcliffe
suffered so many ear infections the
frozen part of the lake that harry
retrieves the sword of gryffindor from
in the deathly hallows was actually
plexiglas with frosted detailing to make
it look frozen from the top beneath they
had real water and when filming shots
looking upwards from under the lake the
top of the ice we see is actually melted
wax that floats on the water while the
underwater scenes look like they were
set in the bottom of a lake they were
actually filming everything in a giant
pool surrounded with blue screen
backgrounds so cgi could be done
afterwards that of course
was hugely challenging the pool was
built especially for the production it
was the deepest underwater tank for
filming in europe 20 feet deep by 60
square feet and able to hold an
impressive half a million liters of
water the massive tank had a filtration
system to manage the chlorine levels
keeping it more pure than mineral water
which helped in keeping the water clear
for filming and it made it much less
irritating for the actor's eyes when
doing these underwater shots the team
didn't plan to record more than around
10 seconds at a time that's as long as
you can do without air and keeping your
eyes open giving radcliffe the
opportunity to take a break and grab
some oxygen from a tank when he needed
it i'm free i'd blow all the air that i
could out of my lungs
not only did he have to swim and act
underwater radcliffe actually had to
speak but his dialogue wasn't recorded
while filming in the giant tank he had
to say the line but he's my friend trebu
and his mouth filled right up with water
but luckily it wasn't too rough of an
experience when it came time to record
his dialogue a much smaller crate was
filled with water and radcliffe would
put his face in it speaking into an
underwater microphone that was hooked up
in the tank
you're sure about this neville
absolutely for an hour more slightly
whenever the harry potter actor was
filming scenes after when he would have
consumed giliweed and needed to show off
gills and webbed feet an hour and a half
of time was spent in the makeup chair
with tricky to work with silicone
prosthetics the job had to be thorough
since the prosthetics needed to be extra
secure to stay in place underwater
amidst all the intense action as for the
filaments inside the gills silk material
wound up being used instead of any
prosthetic because of just how well the
fabric moves underwater
radcliffe's mind was blown as he
encountered and made use of the
underwater sanctuaries used when the
goblet of fire was filming he felt like
a fascinated five-year-old using the
underwater habitat which was essentially
a small tank underwater with windows and
a chimney but it allowed a person to
take off their mask and to be kept dry
and out of water for a minute between
takes the harry potter actor described
it as a low budget version of the big
brother diary room
radcliffe definitely was never on his
own underwater a 20-person diving team
helped make the magic happen in the tank
safely and efficiently one of them was
just there to make sure there weren't
any bubbles in the actor's face or hair
since it was so difficult to film in
these conditions small roles like the
divers in charge of air regulators and
every single camera crew member played a
significant part in making everything
run smoothly 42 hours is nearly the
amount of time radcliffe spent
underwater filming for the fourth movie
alone sometimes spending up to three
hours underwater at a time six months
were dedicated to scuba training alone
and six weeks for filming the scenes
we obviously wanted to get as much
practice in as possible for the
underwater stuff radcliffe's incredible
stunt double david holmes mapped out
what the course should be underwater for
the actor and went through the whole
routine with radcliffe until he knew it
well enough to perform a ton of cgi was
done to create different kinds of plants
to appear underwater as part of the dark
and dank environment they imagined it to
be deep in a giant scottish lock it was
so vast since the water was naturally so
clear they had to muddy up the quality
of visuals underwater consistently the
mer people were tricky because they
needed to look like mythical creatures
while still coming across as
intimidating each creature is designed
because virtually nothing is from the
real world they wound up looking like
deep water mer people with creepy
fish-like mouths the grindylows were
created with cgi but when actually
filming radcliffe was being tugged at by
two stuntmen in blue water suits who
were grappling at him to help him depict
the scene realistically the victor crum
actor had a huge phobia of deep water
and swimming but then he did harry
potter and the goblet of fire where he
had to face his fears you know when
you're breathing that oxygen underwater
yeah and you breathe it too too fast and
too heavily to help ioneski get over his
deepest fear the actor would practice in
the shower allowing the water falling
down from the shower head to overwhelm
him so he could channel being in the
giant tank robert pattinson had some
struggles as well becoming very
disoriented underwater and unaware of
which direction he was really looking in
and what scenes would look like on
camera main thing that really sort of
was a bit frustrating was the fact that
communication is obviously quite
difficult since radcliffe was underwater
every message or note the director had
was passed along through a chain making
the process far less efficient
underwater
it's not as easy as that you know it
also meant radcliffe had to be
completely concentrated while he was
working
i like to think i did okay but i'm not i
just can't be certain
every shot from the underwater scenes
began with a blue screen background that
was lit from behind and then saw the
environment formulated from scratch the
blue screen wound up being extremely
complex especially for the electricians
who had to deal with fluorescent tubes
and cables all around water nothing they
could do with special effects would look
as real as it does when you're doing it
on camera emma watson rupert grint and
daniel radcliffe all went through what
wound up being one of the most annoying
scenes to film together being dropped
into a freezing lake during the harshest
months of winter while normally they
could wear layers the actors needed to
change right after the lake drop meaning
they had to wear as little clothing as
we see them in on screen they didn't
have to do much acting all those shivers
are completely real rupert grint was
pretty preoccupied filming this frigid
scene believing his heart might have
stopped beating from the cold
underwater the language is pretty
different and radcliffe wasn't always
clear on the best communication
practices he once accidentally gave a
hand signal that meant
quick i'm drowning get me up to the
surface and sent everyone into a panic
with the crew acting quickly to save him
fortunately it wasn't the other way
around radcliffe had help whenever he
needed it for all his hard work
radcliffe was given a professional
diver's daily record book for christmas
i have did while filming and in the
total time i spent underwater was 41
hours and 38 minutes the actor was
extremely proud of his diving work and
the memento has the times and lengths of
each dive he made giving an amazing
detailed history of his journey the
whole dive crew also got a special
christmas photo photoshopped for maximum
holiday spirit it clearly took a lot of
work money and extremely skilled
professionals but the final result is
definitely worth it considering how
incredibly realistic all the underwater
scenes look
the actors had their work cut out for
them and rose to the challenge even
though it might have scared some of them
do you think you'd be able to do that
while working underwater